ça rame et beauté merci au public d'être
avec nous chez eux
j'ai pensé à vous tout l'été au japon
[Applaudissements]
tiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tournant
[Musique]
m
battus ou non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mottaki et là c'est ayem haïti
et
[Musique]
à c
tu fais le moonwalk c'est un truc de ouf
[Applaudissements]
j'entends partout
[Musique]
salut pascal bonsoir mr ça qu'on se
connaît peu bonsoir monsieur aliou tu
vas bien ouais ça va alors tu es passé
toi oui je suis passé movies
dès mai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
il ne serait guère avec nous
on va mettre la musique de dirty dancing
attention tu vas faire le porte et fat
en soit ça 3 2 ap
tuvalu ou qui au téléphone acadien
shalalala
ouais je dors je suis désolé mais je
sais pas s'ils étaient au courant tu
l'as vu mon cul wawrinka jeudi éclaté
gasquet je m'éclate et gaël monfils
on m'a approché pour le coup non faut
pas taper à bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au toucher l'eau
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
enfin
tu vas t'entraîner justement de
maintenance et que comme ils regardent
des films porno où les femmes sont
toujours constamment et pire c'est quand
tu vois effectivement la tâche a comme
vous dites ce que vous avez une vérité à
me dire tu as un canard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et lui s'arrête jamais parce qu'il s'est
emparé de mon portable pour envoyer je
te baise encore à quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
olivier rousteing qui est avec lui
j'ai des potes qui voulait dire bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas pour toi
d'anniversaire était prévu un truc away
ne crois pas que tu vas partir comme ça
fait il ya deux jours deux jours les 26
il sait mieux que toi tu t'es con ce mec
savez vous que l'autre est devenu père
d'une petite fille mycroft comment
s'appelle moyens c'est vrai que ces
vendeurs croient que des schémas
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
jobard représentation fait une entrée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voilà autour de la table
il ya un truc voilà qui vous gène est ce
qu'un détail physique
voilà où qui vous plaît énormément ou
qui vous dégoûte quoi qu'il arrive il
pourra rien se passe six mois ses
cicatrices trop sexy voilà les femmes en
une énorme mois
[Rires]
ap tousignant de rock
non notre d'europe moi mais je mange je
mouille le mec c'est has been
pham tuân effet c'est cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
les embrasse moi c'est bon ouais bah ça
veut bien voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'an dernier question bonjour est ce que
ramzi est le plus grand acteur avec qui
tu n'es jamais tourné non non non jean
guy hamelin est ce que si on te proposer
de tourner un prochain film avec
christian clavier
oui et sans être payés oui accepteraient
d'aller gratuitement avec de la
christian est bien sûr que bien sûr mais
aussi c'est pas vrai je suis danseur
d'interview je serai derrière comme dans
ses pas doux pelage que j'aime
bon ben ça donne mais fille choisie
prend le film que je n'étais pas chez le
nil est un animal en général il peut
compliquer adresse à une odeur assez
fort mais finalement on s'attache
oui alors qu'à un moment les hanouna
général chez les animaux qu'ils étaient
capables d'en faire un peu trop sur un
animal qui ont fait naître des enfants
et des animaux sont toujours dans le ton
alors hanouna tendance un petit peu le
no1 et parfois il lance un petit peu
trop de l'année
chocolat